let's go to our next caller we are
taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 our
next caller is from the 5:09 area code
caller what is your name and where are
you calling from hey you this is David
from Spokane Washington
hey great what's on your mind thanks for
having me on David um first I just
wanted to say really appreciate the work
you do a great show especially good at
interviews I just really like your
unravel style thank you anyway um I did
have a question I've kind of been
wanting to ask you about Israel okay
basically I know you're anti BDS yeah
and I just wondered and maybe I missed
this but perhaps there's some other
avenues of BDS that you would advocate
because I know they're like even when
they've done harmless resolutions
against somebody just really like
obstructing so what should we do yours
what should we do about what about the
settlements about about trying to get a
peace deal that's our thing
okay so BDS is not going to help stop
settlements or get a peace deal done and
if anything it's going to hurt and I've
addressed that before we had a caller
earlier who asked sort of my views on
the israeli-palestinian conflict which
you know we can't really sum that up
into it into one phone call but I have
addressed some aspects of that so I'm
against settlements I've made that super
clear and the elimination of any
settlements that can be eliminated is
going to have to happen but I think that
any realistic peace deal is going to
have to concede that there will have to
be land swaps for settlements that
cannot be undone or taken apart I guess
I'm not I just am not totally sure what
you're a laid out what I think is going
to be the path forward there well so
well kind of my kind of angle my angle
on this and maybe you could correct if
I'm if I'm mistaken in some area here
but it worked in South Africa what
worked in South Africa boycotts
divestment
sanctions that's largely what worked in
the port side in South Africa didn't it
yeah but so in what way is the situation
the same in Israel as it is in South
Africa oh oh I'm not sure I'm not saying
it's the same I'm just saying that could
work in one places what specifically
would stop that from being a helpful in
this situation I'm just curious if you
might have something along that well if
the situation if you're conceding that
the situations aren't similar it seems
that it would be more useful if you told
me what you think would affect change
from BDS because it would only make
sense for me to tell you why it wouldn't
work if you conceded that the situations
will decide I don't know if I'd agree
the situations are oh yeah they're
different of course there any two
situations are different but I also
think that there's some similarities
there as well but what about my two
situations - well just I don't know
isn't isn't basically the the
settlements a form of oppression
basically and apartheid was a form of
oppression and you know they use that
botas the fastest for sanctions to deal
with that so right but so you're saying
finding me that's just understand what
you're saying you're saying that because
you're you found depression in South
African apartheid and you find Israeli
settlements to be oppressive that that
makes the situation's analogous in some
way I want to make sure I understand
what you're saying well not just not
just the settlements the settlements the
checkpoints the basically the way that
Palestinians are treated maybe you know
I'm misinformed on that but from what I
understand it there is it isn't a
passive situation you don't you don't
believe that it is well you're asking me
a bunch of different questions here I
mean I think the situation currently in
Israel is is bad it's very bad and it's
very bad
not only for Palestinians but also for
Israelis in many ways that's a separate
question from where there's an analogy
between you know if you're an arab
israeli in israel you have the exact
same rights that a jewish israeli has
who's a citizen of israel right i think
the problem is
you have this situation with checkpoints
and the occupied territories and people
within those territories don't have the
same legal status or rights as citizens
but you know one of the main
distinguishing factors between what's
going on in the israeli-palestinian
conflict and what happened in South
Africa is that if you're an arab-israeli
you have the exact same legal status
rights and privileges as a Jewish
Israeli which that that's not at all
what the situation was like in South
Africa so fundamentally the situations
are very very different you you at least
conceptually understand that yeah yeah I
definitely do I guess I just like the
Western what is the what is the harm
generally with with the boycott
divestment sanctions why why would that
not work or why is it why is it harmful
somehow it's not like a violent action
it's not some is it like maybe I don't
understand this yeah let me lay it let
me lay it out for you here so if you're
an individual who supports the BDS
movement you're not necessarily by
virtue of that anti-semitic you don't
necessarily want to see the elimination
of the State of Israel right as an
individual supporter of BDS it would be
fallacious to assume that you hold those
views however the BDS movement in and of
itself and you can research this and
it's it's widely on record the BDS
movement itself is number one providing
safe harbor for countless anti-semites
who claim to favor BDS for every single
reason other than anti-semitism and in
addition to that BDS does hold as a goal
the elimination of the State of Israel
as we know it so sort of from a systemic
level one of the main I would never
support that and I don't think else like
a second person oh go ahead straight I'm
sorry you don't you don't think what oh
I would never support that and I don't
think you know yeah there's out there
you know fringe anti-semite type people
who might support that but I think that
do you think the average person who
supports BDS thinks that way what I'm
telling you is it doesn't matter because
by supporting the BDS movement you're
supporting a movement
that has the characteristics that I just
mentioned so whether the individual
supporter is or is not someone who
believes those things doesn't matter and
listen I gotta run but the other thing I
would say is it will also be completely
counterproductive in that the BDS
movement in part seeks to boycott
Israeli companies that make it a point
to employ Palestinians from the West
Bank and to work with the system that is
in place to provide jobs to lots of
those people and so in so many ways it's
just completely counterproductive and it
won't achieve its goals it hasn't been
working and it's not going to work
that's my view well I really appreciate
you clearing up your views on that with
me David and again like I said I really
appreciate all the work you do here on
YouTube and also at the radio field all
that so okay great thanks thanks so much
really appreciate it let's take a break
we will be back with more calls after
the break discuss any of these topics
with us on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash re d di t